welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Invincible season 2 just got its
first look in the form of a fast food
date slash meta interrogation of what
the hell Mark Grayson has been up to
over these past two long ass years and
though this trailer is super short and
didn't show any super crazy action shots
from the upcoming season there are a
surprising amount of details that you
could have missed in this trailer of the
greatest superhero show on television
right now that's right I said it I'm not
afraid of you homelander
so let's dive into those Invincible
details that you could have missed in
this teaser trailer shall we but first
of course like always do not forget to
hit up roxasmerch.com so that you can
find new shirts hoodies hats pins all
sorts of really cool nerd stuff over on
that site for you and some that you love
so go to new rockstarsbrush.com today
very good look at that not bad Mark
you're not just Invincible you're also
like earth's best food cooking man
pretty impressive what oh no I I just
worked here I don't actually make the
food all right so this first look at
Invincible season 2 takes place inside
of a burger Mart as indicated by the
massive BM on the window here which
stands for Burger Mart of course but
it's funny because at low-key stands for
bowel movement considering the food at
that restaurant isn't necessarily
prepared in the most sanitary of ways
which is what we learn in episode 5 of
season one when Mark Grayson quits his
employment from that very same
restaurant
what Mr Sayer there's a rat in the
mayonnaise again do I look like I can't
Sam like I don't know if I misheard it
but did that boy say that there was rat
in the mayonnaise that is disgusting
which is likely why Mark is choosing to
scroll Twitter instead of you know
eating anything while his buddy Allen
the alien Chows down on an apparently
delicious Burger Mark rat burger that he
thinks was made by Mark himself since he
used to work there and I really love how
they have Alan eating the burger in such
a weird way on the bare ass table like
the one-eyed alien Dingus that he is
have you not heard of the kova 19 just
kidding you don't have that on your
planet because you're in a better world
um next time also constructive criticism
do not put these green things in here
these are gross hey so did you ever find
a wrath yeah of course I found it uh
very very quickly very easily yellow
Skies purple grass and get this they
have Burgers there too just like these
who would have guessed huh you never
found it right no no not even close I
hope they're okay I think about them
quite a bit honestly and Alan the alien
is of course course a returning
character from season one was sent on
behalf of the Coalition of planets to go
to specific planets to make sure that
those planets were ready for an invasion
from the ruthless vultramite Empire the
Galactic Empire of Superman and
superwomen the invincible's father Omni
man was secretly preserving Earth for
concrete and this meant Alan challenged
one of those planet's strongest
Defenders to make sure that they could
handle the might of a viltramite
Invasion however Alan being that's
one-eyed Dingus that he is instead of
going to the planet araf like the
Coalition of planets told him to he kept
mistaking Earth for wrath and
challenging omniman to fight over and
over again even though he's not supposed
to be there eventually fighting and then
befriending Mark when omniman wasn't
around so having this trainer being a
conversation between Mark and Allen is
fitting considering that season one
ended with Mark Philly Allen in on Omni
man's betrayal and his real plans for
Earth after Allen comes in hilariously
late last minute with a panicked warning
I have to warn you warn me when I return
to the Coalition of planus to tell them
I'd been going to Earth instead of urath
they lost their minds Earth is off
limits there's a filter might living on
your planet oh that what you already
know and finding out that Alan still
hasn't found the planet wrath that he's
supposed to be helping protect while
having a casual Burger on Earth cracks
me up man and it's funny how Alan hates
pickles considering that he is voiced by
Seth Rogen the star of the movie
American pickle where he plays a owner
of a pickle business but uh how about
you what have you been up to it's been a
while I think everyone agrees it's been
like a little ridiculous how long it's
been hey I've been busy doing what
well I've been busy
writing designing a storyboarding voice
acting key posing in between cleaning up
color slapping comping the whole thing
and all that for you know roughly
thousands of shots so it's kind of a lot
then things start to get super meta When
Alan breaks the fourth wall to speak for
the fans when he mentions how ridiculous
the weight between season one and season
two has been and Mark replies in the
best way by speaking for the animators
for the show and how hard they work on
each phase of the show and during the
scripting phase we get our only
potential look as chibi Mark types up a
bloody fight between him and the
superhero known as the immoral the only
surviving member of omniman's Massacre
of the Guardians of the globe and if
this script is accurate and actually
going to happen in season 2 it would
seem that the immortal holds a bit of a
strong grudge against invincible and
blames him just as much as he blames
omniman for the absolute destruction and
Devastation that those two were
responsible for in the season 1 finale
which makes sense considering that Omni
man did Kill The Immortal almost
immediately after the Mahler Brothers
resurrected The Immortal after omniman
killed him the first time so you know
I'd be kind of pissed you and I'm sure
the immortal might not be the only one
who has lost their faith in invincible
and maybe even superheroes in general
after Earth's ultimate protector snap so
feeling that season two is going to
touch on Mark's struggle with helping a
planet that is scared of him and his
potential to rule the planet or destroy
them all something that was briefly
hinted at in one of the final shots of
season one that reveals Cecil secretly
overseeing the construction of an army
of Rihanna men alongside season 1
villain D.A Sinclair behind Mark
Grayson's back Cecil would rather work
with Ezra Miller than trust Invincible
that is a crazy thing likely as a way to
stop Mark if he ever decides to
sympathize with omniman in the
viltramide cause because after going
head-to-head with the Omni man towards
the end of the season Cecil is not about
to take any chances with anime man's son
invincible and neither is the immortal
and then we see HEB Mark selling a suit
for a super cute chibi version of Adam
Eve who my Eagle at homie Jessica
Clemens noted is missing the two circles
around her logo and apparently will be
confirmed as playing a part in the
second episode of season 2 as indicated
by the 202 in both the episode and file
name sections of this document and
judging by these storyboard images it's
implied that Mark himself planned out
the entire teaser trailer that they were
in right now which is super weird and I
love the fact that they had Mark sort of
break down the animation process in the
trailer because it's very much in line
with his love for the comic book
publishing process in the comics but my
favorite part is when Alan looks at the
camera briefly like he's freaked out at
the thought of being a fictional
character in a cartoon when he himself
is the one who was asking Invincible
when season two was gonna come out it's
very meta it's very weird but I love it
when are you going back out there the
world needs more Invincible ah it's
coming okay hey yeah I know but like a
specific date would be nice oh my okay
fine the world will get more Invincible
in uh late 2023. all right and finally
the trailer ends with Mark revealing to
everyone that Invincible will be
returning in late 2023 sort of making
fun how Studios like to give vague
release Windows rather than firm release
dates which I am personally kind of down
for because having hard release dates
sort of encourages the crunching of
artists to get things done on time and
like Mark was alluding to in the trailer
amazing pieces of Animation like
Invincible take time everybody and I for
one am willing to wake however long it
takes but hopefully it's not too long
because uh battle Beast is my son and I
miss him I miss battle B so much
but yes that is the breakdown for the
teaser trailer for invincible I cannot
wait to see our first full in-depth look
of this series and uh we cannot wait to
break down the series for you on this
channel because that is very much on our
radar baby but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at mastertamed on Twitter if
you guys want to see me tweet some weird
[__] and really fun theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on the social medias and
of course do not forget to hit up the
roxasbarch.com where you can buy cool
new nerd [__] for you and those that you
love your accessories.com is the best
but yes thank you guys again for
watching this video we love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]